we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
i got a lot of voicemails about this
recent uh bill maher
segment take a listen to this hey dee
um on the most recent episode of bill
maher's show
like january 30th or something like that
he had two evolutionary biologists on
that not only said that they were 90
sure that coronavirus started in the lab
but they looked a little bit confused at
why the rest of the world
doesn't think that i was wondering if
you had heard anything
about scientists thinking this i i
actually saw the segment and the two
evolutionary biologists that the caller
is referring to
are brett weinstein and uh i i think
it's his wife uh heather haying
haying i'm not sure how to pronounce it
i did see the segment on bill maher and
they they made uh
statements to the to the tone of
they think it's quite plausible that um
the coronavirus
was uh made in a lab in china either on
and it could have been released or maybe
it got out
and um i you know i've exchanged a few
messages over the years with brett
weinstein i've invited him on the
program
before and he's never taken me up on it
uh to me those comments are not the ones
i look to
when i try to you know um i would go to
a virologist
and other folks who specialize in
viruses
for opinions about uh whether there's
any reason to believe that kovid was
man-made and or released on purpose or
accidentally
from a chinese lab i don't know
where evolutionary biologists are
are um getting the framework with which
to say
things like what brett and heather said
and
my view continues to be that of what
virologists are saying
which are and i'm summarizing here
while it has not been definitively
disproven
that kovid could have come from a lab
there is no evidence at this point in
time to believe that that's the case
and that's my position right now and
everybody else can sort of judge for
themselves what they think are
uh reasonable or responsible comments to
be uh to be
be making about that i am not trying to
suppress anyone's speech
i don't think it's something that should
be uh you know
nobody should be barred from
investigating the origins of the virus
and uh that's my understanding of uh
the consensus of virology at this point
in time
we've got a great bonus show for you
today get instant access by becoming a
member
at joinpakman.com